make sure the stream comes up
all right looks like the stream is live
cool okay so welcome to distributed
systems hopefully uh those of you who
are on zoom can hear me
uh you'll the first thing you'll notice
is that the zoom chat is disabled that's
because we won't be using zoom chat
instead we're going to be using
zulip for everything so if you're
enrolled in this class you should have
gotten an invitation to zulip i think
most of you are on it already
according to my uh
messages on zulip um about 80 people
have already signed up
so that's good that's most of who's
enrolled in the class
uh and if you look on the lectures
stream on zulip there's a
topic for lecture one
so hopefully you see that
and this is what we're going to be using
for chat during the course instead of
zoom chat this is good because
it means that uh the chat is persistent
and you won't lose it when the course or
when the when the lecture ends
and you can ask questions about stuff
that we talked about in lecture after
the lecture ends
using this chat all right it looks like
people are finding
the lecture chat on zulip that's great
if you're new to zulip hopefully it'll
be
kind of familiar it's kind of similar to
slack it's kind of similar to discord
and uh hopefully it won't be too
complicated a lot of people
are already using it with aplomb
all right so um so let's get started
uh hopefully you can also see that i'm
sharing my document camera here
um so i got to tell you all
um this is the first time during the
pandemic that i've taught of course in
the afternoon
in the afternoon i do not have child
care and i have a three-year-old
daughter
so there's a
a small but real chance that my daughter
could pop in
at any moment i hope you like toddlers i
also have a cat
the cat is less likely to come in
because the cat can't open doors but it
still could happen
so just to warn you those things could
occur
so i want to start
i want to start by just giving an agenda
for today
so we're going to talk about
logistics administrative stuff
expectations
and then we're going to start getting
into the actual content of the course so
distributed systems
what and why
and if you could mute yourself on zoom
if you're not talking right now that'd
be great
all right so um
let's start with the administrative
stuff
first of all if you haven't found it yet
we have a course website
composition dot a-l-slash cse
2021 i like to do things in public
so our public course overview and public
schedule and all that stuff is there
if you have not checked out the course
website yet i encourage that you do so
a lot of what we do in this course is
going to be done in public um
so the lectures are public uh the
schedule for the course is public
uh even things like uh the the
expectations for grading will be public
the assignments will not be public so
assignments are one thing that are
private uh but just about everything
else is public
and to me this makes things a lot more
fun
it means that you know people around the
world can see what we're doing and
participate
um so so this is how i like to do things
rather than keeping everything all
locked up in our
course management system uh so this is a
public
uh web page that you can go and check
out on that page right now the main
things are the course overview
and the schedule so hopefully
some of you have already taken a look at
those and
thanks to those of you who have i'm not
going to read over everything for
you in the course overview and schedule
but i'm gonna hit the highlights
and then you can take the time to check
it out on your own i recommend that you
read the course overview yourself from
top to bottom because
there's a lot of info in there that you
might find useful
but i'll just go over the highlights
right now so
um so first of all me i'm lindsay cooper
i've been here at uc santa cruz for
how long i guess is my third year
and um well
i wasn't expecting to tell you the truth
that
i was going to be teaching this course
online for the second time
this is the second time that i have
taught this course
online i taught it online last spring as
well
and if you had told me back then that i
was going to be teaching it online again
uh i would have been pretty sad but
that's the situation that we're in
um and um
you know now this means that a third of
my career here at ucsc has been
teaching online uh hopefully not that
much more
but we'll see um so my research is in
the area of kind of the combination of
of programming languages and distributed
systems i like to say that
i work on solving systems problems with
programming languages solutions
so if you want to know more about me and
my research i would love to talk with
you more about it
probably in office hours or you know you
can ask me questions on zulip or
wherever
i probably won't spend too much time
talking about my research
during regular lectures because we need
this time to talk about our
kind of main course content but you know
if we get to the end
and the end of the course and there's
time
then maybe i will talk about my own
stuff a little bit we'll see it depends
also on what you're interested in that
kind of thing
so that's me uh we also have uh some
great course staff
so i wanna i wanna briefly introduce
them to you
uh we have two teaching assistants uh
both of them are people that i have
worked with before
and who i trust and who i think are
great so
one of our teaching assistants is abhay
and the other is patrick
both of them are going to be holding
discussion sections the discussion
sections are optional
so you're not required to go but
discussion sections are a good place to
go
if you have questions about homework
especially once the homework assignments
start coming out or if you have
questions about any of the course
content
they also in addition to the sections
our rtas are going to hold office hours
and the times for those are listed on
the course overview as well and you can
check that out
oh i forgot to mention i too will be
holding office hours but i haven't
decided exactly when that will be yet so
i will update the
the course overview when i get that
sorted out
so some folks are asking some questions
about like what where the best place to
watch
lecture is if you're enrolled in the
class so
yeah i mean you have a choice between
zoom and twitch
um so you're right that things might be
less laggy on twitch
actually interestingly enough um
and but there is this downside right
that twitch shows ads from time to time
and i have nothing to do with that i
can't
control it and i certainly don't make
any money from it
uh so um i apologize for the ads
uh if you want an ad free experience
which you're entitled to as a student
then go with zoom um
[Music]
hopefully that answers that question
all right back to course staff so this
is uh these these are wonderful tas
uh we also have some tutors uh and
we have four tutors uh i'm just gonna
list their
their first names here we have
arya
matthew arjun
and
vinay the role of the tutors
is to hold tutoring sections
and those are going to be advertised on
zulip
and probably also listed in the
you know list of zoom sessions that you
can find on canvas
and also to answer questions on zulip
basically anytime that you have them
if you need to reach the course staff
there is a zulip shortcut for that
you can just at mention
course staff on zulip
and that will reach all these people
at once and this is really the way to go
like if you need to talk to the course
staff if you have a question for the
staff
um rather than trying to contact either
each of us individually do this
and then you'll be able to talk to us
all
questions about any of this stuff so far
all right
yeah um so well i guess that's up to the
tas if they want to record their own
um but i you know i wouldn't count on it
happening uh
and um so office hours certainly not
i think office hours are intended to be
more of a
that that's that's like if you want to
know what happens at office hours you
should come to office hours
uh and then sections again that's going
to be up to the tas and what they want
to do uh
i don't think that those recordings
would be much help to you anyway
because the questions that will be
answered in office hours will usually be
pretty specific to the person asking so
there would be no reason to sit through
hours and hours of video for that
instead you know if you have a question
ask it on zulip or come to office hours
yourself to get your question answered
rather than
watching extra videos
all right um so
other logistical stuff so just in
general
zulip is the way to do things in this
course so
we're not going to be using a canvas
announcements
we're not going to be using piazza uh
we're not going to be using email very
much
uh instead zulip will take the place of
all those things
we will be using canvas for grades and
we will be using canvas
for distributing assignments um but for
basically everything else
zulip is the place to go so
if you have not yet done so you should
enable
notifications for the announcement
stream on zulip
so announcements is a stream where we're
going to post
like course announcements and things
that you should know
i'm going to try to keep from spamming
it it's going to be stuff that you
actually need to know
um so if i have things to say that
aren't so essential i'll probably post
them in the general
stream or somewhere else but for things
that
are really important for everybody to
know i'll put them in announcements so
uh you should set up your your um zulu
notifications so that you get
those announcements as far as other
channels
uh i don't care if you turn on
notifications or not you can do whatever
works for you
and zululup is nice in that it lets you
configure notifications on this per
channel basis so you can set it up
however you want it
all right let's see before i get into
course content stuff
let's see is there any other
logistical stuff that i want to cover
how about this okay so uh
i want to mention if you have a
disability
and you need accommodations for this
course
uh talk to me about it so there are both
official
and you know accommodations that we can
offer through the
disability resource center and
you can also contact me even if you
don't have a drc letter
and there's there's some kind of
accommodation that you want to ask for
um you can talk to me about it and i am
i am very eager to help you get the most
out of the course
uh i've gotten you know a lot of people
have talked to me about how
they've um you know they might not have
necessarily known
that they had a learning disability
until they started taking online courses
and you know i myself uh i took an adhd
evaluation the other day and it turned
out i had moderate
adhd symptoms so and
you know it doesn't in the end like it
doesn't really matter if you have
a diagnosis or not i still want to run
the course in the way that is most
helpful
so um that said if you
if you can get that authorization letter
to get things like
accommodations and tests and so on then
that's really useful to have
so it's not too late you can still talk
to the drc about getting accommodations
and you know if you do think you might
need something something like
accommodations for extra time on exams
uh then i suggest talking to them sooner
rather than later
uh so there's a link you know hopefully
you know most of you know about this
already
but there's a link on our course
overview to the drc where you can learn
more about
what they have to offer and you know i
encourage you to do so
okay so let's talk a little bit about
what we're going to actually be doing in
this course
so this is a course
that's about fundamental concepts of
distributed systems what does that mean
so first of all what is a distributed
system
i'm going to start with the definition
that was
originally intended as a joke but
i think that there's like so many good
jokes there's truth to this joke
so the definition that's a joke
is a distributed system is a system
where i can't get my work done
because some computer somewhere
that i've never even heard of has failed
and this definition comes from leslie
lamport
who is often thought of as the father of
distributed systems
so somewhere somewhere a computer has
failed
that i've never even heard of and
because of that i can't get my work done
that's a distributed system now he meant
this as a joke of course
but there's a lot of truth to this joke
so we're going to try to explore and
write down a definition of distributed
systems that
kind of explains you know
why why did he make this joke so
so here's one definition
and this is a definition from
martin klepman
who's another uh really
great distributed systems educator and
so he says a distributed system
is
running on several nodes
we'll talk about what a node is in a
second
connected by network
and
characterized by
partial
failure
partial failure so what do i mean by
that
so if the if the failure is partial this
must mean that some parts of the system
are broken
while other parts are okay
or sometimes broken or maybe broken
and furthermore it's often impossible
to know what exactly is broken or it's
least
impossible for the software to know
what's broken
so we'll come back later in the course
to what we mean exactly by this idea of
impossible for the software to know
um but let me go back to this here when
i say nodes what is a node well
we can think of a node as being a
computer or
an instance of some software running on
a computer
right which communicates with other
nodes
in a network in order to accomplish some
sort of task
so these are the two key pieces of
cluttman's definition he says the
distributed system has to be running on
several nodes or several computers
and that partial failure is a key
characteristic
of this system and i think this is a
pretty good
definition it kind of captures the key
things about that
joke from leslie lamport that we heard a
second ago there are multiple computers
no one of them here one of them
somewhere else
and there's failure and failure is
endemic to this system
so that's what i think a distributed
system is um
what about you uh do you have any ideas
about what we should
what should fall under this definition
of distributed systems if you have a
thought then
go ahead and put it in zulip or you can
say it out loud if you want to
parallelism yeah okay so if we have
multiple computers
right then we certainly have the
potential
of doing computation of using that
resource right of these multiple
computers to do computation faster
right so parallelism is a resource
that we can use to get tasks done faster
if we use it well
okay somebody else suggests partitioning
tasks across multiple nodes yeah okay
so in
in this course we're going to be talking
about you know algorithms that are
designed to run on more than one
computer
and when there's a lot of work to do you
can get it done faster
if you split up the work okay now folks
are talking about
fault tolerance good okay
yep because of this partial failure
we're certainly going to want to talk
about how to deal
with that partial failure so
so this is great folks are talking about
you know speeding up work by
partitioning the work across multiple
nodes and
talking about fault tolerance and and
and so on
so and these are things that people have
brought up in the past when i've taught
this course
uh and people have even even said things
like
multiple computers running as a single
computer
uh and so these definitions i think are
good
and these are all things that we're
going to talk about but i would
also caution you that these kinds of
definitions are very optimistic
right so you know of course we want our
distributed
systems to be fault-tolerant uh we want
to be able to take advantage of this
resource of parallelism
but also we have to keep in mind that
you know a lot of distributed systems
don't tolerate faults very well
a lot of distributed systems don't take
advantage of parallelism very well
and part of what we're going to be
spending a lot of time talking about in
this course
is the kind of failures that can occur
and the kind and the way that we need to
design distributed algorithms
defensively in order to
guard against those kinds of failures
all right so i want to talk a little bit
more about this concept of partial
failure
so i say that a partial failure is when
some parts of a computation or some
parts of a system could be broken
while other parts are are okay um
so that's kind of interesting right
that's like
not what we're normally used to dealing
with
um and so if you were just talking about
a single machine
for example then
well we typically think of you know if
one part of a computation
fails then it all fails so a traditional
example of this i know everybody here
has taken 130
um so you know a little bit about
operating systems
so when in os kernel panics
that means that some part of the os has
failed right
and now the os has crashed
so some part has failed and because some
part has failed the whole thing fails
and you have to start over
so normally on a single machine
we don't talk about this concept of
partial failure
this notion of partial failure comes up
more
the more computers that we have
so there are some different philosophies
here and i want to contrast
two ways of thinking about this
so one one philosophy is i'm what i'm
going to call the cloud computing
philosophy
and the other one is what i'm going to
call the
high performance computing
philosophy
so let's talk about the the hyper
performance computing philosophy first
or the hpc philosophy
so a typical approach in this in this
hpc philosophy
is to treat partial failure as total
failure
so if one part of a computation fails
then
that's it start over
and a typical thing to do in these
settings is to use what's called
checkpointing
so check pointing is one way to deal
with these
inevitable failures right so if you have
some computation running on
many machines and a machine fails
then if you've been taking snapshots of
that computation as you go along which
is what we
what we mean by check pointing then
when a failure occurs you can go back to
the point that you've checkpointed and
resume the computation from there
so this is a way of dealing with failure
on the other hand there's this cloud
computing philosophy
and this differs from the hpc philosophy
in that rather than treating a partial
failure as a total failure
we
treat partial failure
as expected
and work around it
so in this approach if you've got a
bunch of machines and one of them
fails then you keep going you find a way
to keep
going even though a machine has failed
or maybe several machines have failed
so why would you choose to do one or the
one of these or the other
well so this this hpc philosophy
can work pretty well if you don't have
too many
machines right if failure doesn't happen
that often
and you don't have too many machines um
then then this could be okay
right let's say you have four computers
and they're all talking to each other
and you don't expect a failure to happen
all that often
well you know maybe once in a while
one of the computers will fail um but
if you're checkpointing as you go along
and you don't expect those failures to
happen that often
anyway then this can be an okay way to
go you know one of the machine fails
it's okay to start over from wherever
your last checkpoint was
but let's say that instead of having
four computers you have four hundred 000
computers
so this increases the likelihood
that any given computer is going to fail
or
sorry it doesn't increase the likelihood
that any given computer is going to fail
but it increases the likelihood that
some computer is going to fail
right because the more computers you
have
uh other things being equal the more
likely it is the computer is going to
fail at some point
so if you have a lot of computers the
more computers that you have
you would really like to be able to keep
operating in the event of a failure
so these are both considered approaches
to distributed systems and they're both
good approaches
the the cloud compute the cloud
computing philosophy what we
what we think of is this idea of of
expecting failures and working around
failures and designing algorithms in
this defensive way that can tolerate
failures
this is kind of what you need to do them
if you really have a lot of computers
and so this is what this approach is
what we're going to be spending most of
our time talking about in this course
because in a big enough system the the
probability is high
that something's broken there's a great
quote about this
um from warner vogels who's the the cto
of amazon
and he says very simply
everything fails all the time
so if you're in a world where you expect
everything to fail all the time
then the way to go is to put the extra
effort into design your algorithms
design your systems in a way that
expects that failure
and can work around it and so that's
what we're going to be concentrating
more of our attention on in this course
questions about that so far
oh
all right okay so i've been talking and
talking and talking about failure
um let's talk about what we mean by that
what are some ways in which a
distributed system could
fail
well let's think about a very very
simple distributed system
so let's say we just have two machines
m1 and m2 it's the simplest distributed
system that i can think of
and let's say that these
two machines are running a very simple
algorithm simplest algorithm i can think
of that involves both these machines
is m1 wants to make a request to m2 and
get a response
so let's say that m1 wants to ask m2
what's the value of x
maybe x is some some variable that's
stored on m2
and then maybe m2
believes that x is five
so m two will respond
so it's a super simple exchange of
messages
what could go wrong
in this incredibly simple distributed
system what do you think what are some
of the ways in which this could go wrong
all right we're starting to get some
good answers here
okay so one of the responses here is
m2 never receives the request so
what are some reasons why m2 might not
receive the request
well um
it could get lost on the way to m2
so let's just start listing out ways in
which this could go wrong so
the request from m1 gets lost it never
gets to m2
why would this happen it could happen
for all sorts of reasons
um maybe a backhoe comes along and takes
out the cable
that goes between m1 and m2
this is less likely to happen if m1 and
m2 are in the same data center
but if they're on opposite sides of the
world there are a lot of things that
could go wrong
so request could get lost from one to
the other
okay
oh here's an interesting one somebody
suggests what if x is updated
during the request so maybe you make a
request
and then meanwhile over here
the value of m2 changes so you get back
uh
an answer that's different from whatever
uh whatever m2 thinks the answer is so
or maybe you get back this answer five
but in the time that it takes
uh for that answer to get back to you
maybe
x changes over here maybe somebody else
comes along and updates x
so that would be a concurrency issue um
now those sorts of issues still are in
play
even on a single machine right so you
could still have multiple threads that
are trying to
access the same memory uh if you have
multiple threads that are sharing memory
and so you could still have those sorts
of of concurrency
issues even on one machine but we will
talk about that stuff
in this course now here because we only
have these two machines
i'm imagining just for this very simple
picture and i'm imagining that there's
not another machine over here that's
also
sending updates that are setting next to
something else
but that could happen right and that is
something that we're going to have to
think about as we get further along in
the course
what else could go wrong ah somebody
said corrupt transmission so that's an
interesting one i'm actually going to
put
something about that at the end here
we'll come back to that one
okay so what are some of the other
things that could go wrong well
here's something that hasn't been
mentioned yet but it's kind of similar
uh to to point number one
what if the request from m1 is just
really really slow
so maybe it doesn't get lost
but maybe it just takes a really really
long time to get there
well no m1 can't wait forever to get an
answer back how long should it wait
we don't really have a great answer to
that question
so maybe it's just slow and note that
the slowness could happen in the network
or maybe the slowness could happen on m1
side maybe m1 has a q
where it's queuing up messages to be
sent out
or maybe the slowness could happen on m2
side maybe m2 has a queue
where it's receiving messages so this
slowness could happen in the network or
it could happen
on either one of these machines and you
might not know
if you're the application on m1 that's
uh that's trying to figure out what the
value of x is
you might not be able to tell from your
point of view
which kinds of which kind of slowness
you're dealing with
here's another one that somebody just
suggested in chat m2 could receive the
request but it could fail
while trying to process the request so
m2 crashes
what if m2 gets the request from m1 and
then immediately crashes
right so there was nothing wrong with
the network network was fine
message got there quickly but then m2
crashed upon receiving the message who
knows why
maybe it had nothing to do with the
message maybe it was a crash for some
other reason
what else well what let's say that the
message gets to m2 promptly
let's say that m2 doesn't crash
and responds but we still have problems
right
because what if m2 is slow
uh what if the message is slow getting
back right
um actually there's a couple of
different issues here so one could be
m2 is just slow to respond right and the
slowness is is purely m2's fault
so maybe m2 is super backed up with
requests
and it can't get a response back
promptly
and then we could have slowness in the
network on the way back from m2 to m1
so response
from m2 is slow and then the response
could also just get lost
right
okay this last one corrupt transmission
this could mean lots of different things
um but let me give one example of
something that could go wrong
what if m2 has been compromised right
what if m2 lies to m1
or what if there's some other kind of
interference where
you send a message but some kind of an
attacker comes along
and corrupts the message somehow
these things are known as what's called
byzantine faults
we're not going to be spending a huge
amount of time on this but we'll talk
about this later in the course
[Music]
all right so i think that these things
cover most of the things that people
were suggesting that could have gone
wrong here
um we didn't really talk too much
like these don't really cover this
situation where you might have another
machine here because adding a third
machine adds even more complication
but even just in this situation with
these two machines look at all the
different things that can go
wrong so
here is my question for you
if you were m1 and you send this request
to m2 and you don't get a response back
do you have any way of knowing which of
these things went wrong here
what do you think yeah
so okay you could take a guess maybe you
have some historical data
about things that have gone wrong
you can check network interfaces
somebody suggests can you go into a
little bit more detail about that
yeah okay you can check if you have
network access
sure uh yeah so
certainly like if you can't send a
message out at all
then that's a problem right if you're on
one and you can't send a message out at
all
then you know that there's a problem but
if you're able to send a message
and then you don't hear back you really
don't have much
of a way to know which of these things
could have gone wrong
you could have successfully sent the
message and then it could have gotten
lost on the way to the other machine
it could have just been slow maybe the
other machine crashed
maybe the other machine is just slow to
respond
maybe the response is slow or maybe the
response got lost
or maybe it's a byzantine fault where
maybe m2 is uh is malicious right maybe
m2
got your request just fine and is just
refusing to answer
so i'm kind of categorizing corrupt
transmission under there too because
byzantine faults include both corrupted
transmissions and also just
m1 having any kind of arbitrary or
malicious behavior
so we could differentiate between
different kinds of byzantine faults and
we'll talk about that more later when we
talk about fault classifications
but for now we're kind of letting this
be its own
category of bad things so
you really don't have a whole lot of way
to tell
what happened right and so this is so
important that i'm going to write it
down separately
if you send a request to another node
and don't receive a response
it is impossible
for you to know why
it's impossible for you to know for sure
that makes our life pretty hard doesn't
it as people who are trying to build
distributed systems and design
distributed systems
so what do real systems do how do real
systems deal with this problem
what do you do when you make a request
to another machine
okay a couple of suggestions here ask
again if it fails
and wait for an act to be received okay
so how long do you wait
when you say ask again if it fails
how long do you wait before asking again
right
yeah it depends so
you need to have some sort of notion
about what's called a timeout right
so what's a timeout
good yeah somebody just suggested set a
timeout
what is timeout after some amount of
time if there's no response
give up and assume failure and maybe try
again
but why might it be wrong
to assume failure
sure yeah the node could still be
working
or the message could just be slow in the
network
yeah so this is an imperfect solution
so how long should your timeout be right
as somebody just suggested in chat if
the timeout's too short
you might never get the answer if you
ask for
for an answer and you assume failure
before there's been enough time for that
message to get to the other machine
then oh you might be in trouble how long
does it take for a message to get
around the world well let's say let's
just say that it takes 100 milliseconds
maybe it takes 150 milliseconds if your
timeout is 10 milliseconds but you're
talking to a machine on the other side
of the world
then good luck right
so this is not a great solution here's
another reason why it's not great
suppose that instead of just asking what
the value of x is
suppose you were doing this
suppose that your message was to
increment x over here on m2
so x was five before
and then your increment shows up
now x is six and maybe m2 is supposed to
send some sort of an acknowledgement if
you send the increment
and it times out
what happened do you know whether the
increment happened
if your request times out well
maybe not right
what if the message that you sent gets
over there
and the increment are hurt occurs and
then this acknowledgement this okay
message
gets lost on the way back to you well
then that means that your ex duly got
incremented over here on m2
you never got the acknowledgement so
from your point of view over on m1
it didn't happen even though it actually
did
so from your point of view you see that
your request
timed out and that can happen even
though the request actually took effect
so if you're m1 and you don't get that
okay response
you don't know whether the increment
happened if you get the response then
you can assume it happened but
assuming no byzantine faults right
assuming that there are no
man-in-the-middle attacks or anything
like that
um but if you don't get that response
maybe the increment happened and maybe
it didn't and it would be wrong for you
to assume that it did or that it didn't
so there's a lot of uncertainty here
uncertainty is a fundamental
characteristic of distributed systems
and that's what we mean when we say it's
impossible for you to know why
you didn't receive a response and if
it's a message that has some sort of
side effect over here on m2 then
you really don't know whether that side
effect took place or not so
yeah we're going to be talking more
later about
avoiding requests that do side effects
right
sometimes you won't be able to avoid
side effects but
in this setting where you have all this
uncertainty
avoiding side effects is one of the key
tools in your toolbox to avoid
bad things questions about any of this
yeah so there's a great question in chat
just now doesn't the timeout add
additional overhead
right yeah so if you choose a timeout
that's really long
then it means you can get less work done
than you might like you know
if you have to wait for that timeout to
uh to expire
before you can do something else then
you might really be throttling the
amount of work that you can get done
on the other hand if you choose a
timeout that's too short
then you're also going to be in trouble
so there's not any perfect answer here
i can't tell you what kind of a timeout
would be appropriate for a given
situation
and we're going to be talking about in
most of the time in this course we're
going to be talking about networks where
we don't know how long it takes for a
message to get from one place to another
we're going to be talking about networks
where the latency
from one machine to another could be
arbitrarily long
so in that kind of a setting
there's no good answer for how long our
timeouts should be
all right
so i didn't mention this earlier but
this is the first time that i've taught
this course tuesday thursday rather than
monday wednesday friday
so if this were a tuesday or
if this were a monday wednesday friday
course it would only be 65 minutes long
and we would be coming to the end of the
first lecture right now
uh but this is a tuesday thursday course
and so our lectures are 95 minutes
i have to say i think 95 minutes is
really long especially for an online
course
and um i you know i want to make sure to
give you breaks
so the way that we're going to do this
is
i'm going to post a quiz question uh in
the middle of
every lecture and we'll take a 10 minute
break
and during that 10-minute break what you
should do is
try to answer the quiz question and then
you know do whatever you need to do
go get some water get some coffee get up
and stretch
but in my opinion 95 minutes is too long
to sit staring at a computer so try to
get your eyes away from the screen at
some point
um so it's about time i think for our
first quiz question
and the way that we're going to do this
is uh there's a google form
i will post the link to it on zulip and
i'll also just share the question right
here
so let's see
so here's our quiz question hopefully
you can see it and i'm also going to
share the link on zulip right now
so with these quiz questions
um you're not going to be evaluated on
what you
answer you're only going to be evaluated
on
whether you answer
so i don't want you to stress about it
too much i just want you to do your best
all right i've just posted the link on
zulip in our lectures
uh in our in our lecture one chat topic
so go ahead and answer and i'm gonna set
a timer for 10 minutes
and in about 10 minutes we will resume
have a good break
you
uh
about two minutes to go on the timer
all right 10 minute timer just went off
for me
hopefully you had a chance to stretch
your legs get your eyes away from the
screen for a second
uh let's go back to the lecture so
we just got done talking about
how real systems try to cope with this
impossibility
of knowing why a request might have
failed
and how timeouts are what we're forced
to do but how timeouts are an imperfect
solution
so one of the biggest causes of
uncertainty in this particular example
is network latency so what do i mean by
that
well i mean the time that it takes for a
message to get
from one uh from one machine to another
if we were lucky enough to know that
there was some sort of
maximum delay for messages between m1
and m2
then that would make our lives a whole
lot easier right
if if we knew for example that there was
a maximum
delay
of d where d is some some units of time
between m1 and m2
then that would be great right because
then we could know
that we could rule out certain kinds of
problems
so for example let's say that the
maximum delay is d
and let's say that the maximum time
that m2 spends processing a request is
r
if that is the case if the maximum delay
between m1 and m2 is d and the maximum
time that m2 might spend processing a
request is is
r then what should m1 pick
for a timeout when it's sending a
request to m2
how long of a timeout should it have
what do you think
good yeah so somebody just said 2d plus
r
so this is great to know right earlier
we were saying that it's hard to know
how long a timeout should be
but if we know how long this this
maximum latency is between these
machines and we know how long m2 is
going to take
now we know exactly how long our timeout
needs to be right
and that rules out a lot of uncertainty
that we had before
it's still of course it doesn't solve
all our problems right
m2 can still crash and
um we could still have network
connections fail right because a backhoe
could still take out a network cable
um but uh but this would solve a lot of
our problems
unfortunately most of the time we cannot
do this
so we can make a guess at what d should
be
we can make a guess at what r should be
but
most of the time we don't know right so
somebody just asked
how do you figure out the maximum
latency and the answer is honestly most
of the time you can't
you can collect statistics over time so
earlier i was saying
what if you have a machine on the other
side of the world let's say it takes
uh um 150 milliseconds for a message to
get there
well uh or for a message to get there
and back
well no that 150 is based on
maybe statistics that we gather over
time so that gives us some idea
uh but um but that might uh
that might not necessarily be what
always happens
right and it might be an average but not
a maximum
right so this isn't really something
that we can normally have
and for the most part in this course
we're going to be talking about
networks that are known as asynchronous
networks i'll talk about this more in a
minute
but in an asynchronous network
there is no maximum latency between
nodes
so we want to design our systems in a
way that tolerates that asynchrony
so my colleague peter alvaro likes to
say
that in distributed systems we have to
deal with both partial failure and
unbounded latency and in fact this is
how peter defines distributed systems
so peter's definition
so
so most of the time we're not going to
be lucky enough to
have this information and again you know
we can make a guess
and maybe that guess is going to be good
enough most of the time
but it's not going to be
correct all the time and you know some
of the time
we're going to experience weird behavior
and the more machines that we have
the more likely it is that any machine
at any given time is going to be doing
something weird
so most of the time
we can't do this instead we have to
design our algorithms and design our
systems in such a way that we tolerate
unbounded latency and that's really hard
to do
it means that a lot of stuff that we
might like is impossible
so a lot of things that you want in
distributed systems turn out to be
impossible and you have to try to
do your best to deal with them
regardless okay
so doom and gloom
right i've been talking about all this
terrible stuff
all these ways in which a very simple
distributed
request response protocol could fail
all this this dealing with unbounded
latency
it sounds really painful doesn't it who
wants to deal with this
so why would you want a system like this
given how horrible they are
given how miserable they can be to
program why would you want any of this
why would you want a distributed system
why deal with all this pain
so i want to throw this question out to
you
why deal with all this pain why are you
taking this painful course
why would anyone deal with all this pain
folks are saying honestly i'm taking the
course because distributed systems sound
cool okay
it's really cool pain
yeah okay
so one good suggestion here is throwing
many computers at a problem can solve it
faster
so one reason to deal with all this pain
is
you want to make things faster
sometimes you can make things faster by
using more computers
and we'll talk about this more later on
in the course as well especially when we
talk about map reduce near the end of
the course
uh but yeah sometimes you want to make
things faster
and sometimes to make things faster you
have to use more computers and then
look you've ended up with a distributed
system
all right what are some other reasons
why you would deal with all this
pain
well maybe you have no choice right why
would you have no choice
maybe you you need multiple machines
because you have more data than can fit
on one machine
so there's no way right there's no way
to do your comp
the computation that you want to do on a
single machine you can scale up that
computer you can try to
be able to to scale it up as much as you
can
and often that's the right way to go
right load up one machine with
as much memory as you can as much
storage as you can and try to keep that
using
that one machine until further notice
right
but at some point that stops scaling
just like at some point you can't build
a skyscraper any higher at some point
you have to build another building
and uh and we'll talk more about that
later too but yeah one reason to deal
with all this pain is because you you
just have more data
than you can fit on one machine and so
you need multiple machines and now all
of a sudden you have to deal with
the reality of distributed systems
so some folks are talking about
reliability
yeah okay so it's interesting right
because we just talked about all this
notion all this kind of failure right
all this kind of failure that can occur
but on the other hand if you just have a
single machine
and that machine dies then
you're screwed right if all your data
was just on that one machine
and then that machine dies too bad no
more data for you
so more machines could give you
reliability
right and we'll talk about that later on
in the course when we start to talk
about replication and so on
so anytime that you deal with let's say
gmail or google drive
or any of those tools there's more than
one copy of your
data you don't see it but behind the
scenes
in a google data center somewhere
there's more than one copy of all of
those emails there's more than one copy
of all of those files
so that if a machine fails that's
storing your data
there will be another one there and your
your emails or your
uh your your files won't be lost forever
same goes for i mean we're using zulip
right now
i'm not sure what zulip uses i imagine
maybe they use aws so maybe they use
amazon web services
uh for um for storing data
so when i post a cat picture on zulip uh
there's more than one copy of that cat
picture now somewhere
in the world right there of course there
was the copy on my computer
but now that it's on zulip that cat
picture
is now copied and replicated in multiple
places
and so we get some reliability out of
using a distributed system
of course there's a trade-off because
now that there are these multiple copies
those copies have to be kept in sync
with each other and we'll talk about
that more when we when we discuss
replication in a minute or a little bit
later in the course
all right somebody just mentioned
throughput yeah so
if i have one machine here and somebody
else has another machine
in tokyo and so i i happen to be in the
bay area
if somebody in oregon
needs to make a request to either me or
the person in tokyo
who is it better for them to make a
request to well
it's probably better if they make the
request to me right
meanwhile somebody else uh
who's in uh who's in kyoto
they should probably make the request to
the person in tokyo
so that adds a level of
of availability
if the data is close to whoever needs it
and that's only possible if you have
multiple copies of the data so that
a certain copy can be close to whatever
client needs it
and that's also how systems like
amazon's s3 and so on are designs
they're going to be multiple
copies of that cat picture around the
world for anybody who might need it
wherever they need it and so that
you don't have to wait 100 milliseconds
for the cat picture and instead maybe
you only have to wait
10 milliseconds or 20.
so reliability throughput
i'm throwing a bunch of words out here
and
we haven't necessarily defined all of
these terms and these are all going to
be things that we spend
the rest of the of the term talking
about so
i'm not going to write down definitions
for all this stuff right now
uh instead i just want to give you a
general idea of why this pain of
distributed systems is worthwhile
and we're going to be exploring all
these
all these topics as we go through the
course
so in the 15 minutes or so that we have
left
i want to talk a little bit about how
this course is going to be structured
and again this is information that is
part of the course overview which you
should read
but knowing that no not everybody
absorbs information by reading or
whatever
i want to spend a little time talking
about it right now
so
maybe a good way to explain this is is
to talk about kind of the components of
your grade in this course
uh so
there's kind of four things that we want
to be concerned with
so
surveys and lecture quizzes like the
quiz that you just did a minute ago
these are going to be 10 of your grade
so this is you know kind of a small
percentage but it's not nothing right
and this these these should be basically
free points
so as i mentioned before i'm not going
to grade you on the content
of what you write in your response to
the lecture quiz
i'm going to i'm only going to grade on
the existence of your response so
you know if you if i ask a question in a
lecture quiz
and you have no idea and you write i
have no idea you actually still get
credit for that
so there's no reason not to respond
uh surveys here i also mentioned surveys
so some of you have already filled out
the start of course survey thank you
in the past i've always done these
surveys and i never made them a
component of the grade before which
meant that
people didn't necessarily do them so i
decided this time
you know even though i don't like
grading on this sort of thing i decided
to get people to do the start of course
survey and later there will be a middle
of the course survey
i decided to make them worth a small
number of points
so if you haven't yet done this survey
please do it
uh by friday uh i assure you it's not
very hard
yeah so this is basically 10 10 of your
grade is basically free points if you
come to lecture
and you um you fill out these these
lecture quizzes and you fill out these
surveys
uh those are those are free points for
you so
translated into points this means 50
points in the way that we do points in
this class
there's going to be two exams a midterm
and a final
um so the midterm is going to be 20
the final is going to be 24 of your
grade
so this is 100 points
this is 120 points
i'm telling you all this right now
because i like to be very transparent
about how things are going to work
so all together this is um
or 220 points
um and then there is very importantly
the course
project
which is all the rest of the points
and the course project is going to
consist of four assignments
so
20 points for the first assignment and
70 points
each for the rest
so the way that the course project is
going to work is you're going to work in
groups
not for assignment one assignment one is
going to be done by yourself
it's going to be relatively easy and
assignment one is going to come out this
friday
after that you'll be asked to form
groups
so groups are going to be
two to three people
we are asking you to form your own
groups so
we'll be talking more about that a
little bit later
but you can start thinking now about who
you might like to work with in a group
and
i've created a channel on
sorry not a channel they're called
streams on zulip i've created a stream
on zulip where we where you can try to
find teammates
for your group for the course project of
course the next question is obviously
what is the course project about
um so
oh sorry somebody made a correction here
yeah this shouldn't have been 320 that
should have been 230.
thanks for checking my arithmetic all
right so
um yeah so what's the course project all
about
for the course project you are going to
work together with your group
to implement a distributed system
your in particular what you're going to
build is
a key value store so
kind of like that picture that we saw
before uh
where m1 was requesting a value
or rather it was requesting uh it was
making a request on a key it was making
a request on x and it was getting back a
value which was five
you're going to build that um except
it's going to be more sophisticated so
you're going to be building a
distributed
sharded key value store and we'll talk
about what that means
um but there uh the kind of important
components of this
are that um your key value store is
going to have
multiple replicas so that value of x
is going to be stored on multiple nodes
and then it's also going to be sharded
which means that
the set of keys and values that get
stored could be different
on one of those nodes then on another so
not every machine necessarily has
exactly the same
set and that gets back to what i was
talking about a little while ago
when i said that sometimes with
distributed systems you can't fit all
the data on one machine
so in a real distributed system you
might have this situation where you want
to have a key value store but you can't
fit all your key value pairs on one
machine
and so the way to deal with that is to
do what's called sharding the data
across multiple partitions
and so the key value store that you
implement for this class is going to be
able to handle that
so just a rough sketch of what the
assignments are going to involve
and this is this is extraordinarily uh
high level
so assignment one uh
we're going to be using uh what's called
docker if you're not familiar with
docker
you will become familiar with it in the
first assignment so
docker is a platform for what's called
containerization
um so assignment one is basically about
learning to use docker
and this is not going to be material
that we really cover in lecture
rather you're going to be learning this
by reading the documentation yourself
which we're going to share with you
and figuring it out on your own you may
use
any programming language any framework
any tools that you want instead you're
we're not so we're not going to grade
you on your choice of any of that stuff
uh we're not going to pick favorites uh
we can give suggestions about what
popular choices have been in the fat in
the past but i'm not going to endorse
any particular choice
instead what you're going to do is
implement a web service that presents a
certain api
and then we're going to test it by
making requests against that api and
checking what the responses are
so behind the scenes you can implement
your web service using
whatever language you want whatever
framework you want and so on
and so this is great for you right
because it gives you and your team a lot
of freedom about how you do things
uh but it also means that you have to
make some design choices
so now is a good time just maybe start
asking some questions about you know
what kind of
programming language your teammates
might want to use
what kind of tools do you want to use
and so on and
you know i'll talk a little bit more as
the course goes along about
what typical choices have been in the
past but again i'm not going to endorse
particular things
it's completely up to you so that's
assignment one
assignment two uh you're going to do a
simple
let's say not distributed key value sort
so kvs here is short for key value store
assignment 3
that's where we're going to get into
replication
which is going to improve the fault
tolerance of our key value store
an assignment for
that's where we're going to get into
sharding or partitioning which is going
to improve
the scalability of our key value store
and in the end
you will have implemented a non-trivial
distributed system together with your
team
so all this is going to intersect with
the kinds of things that we talk about
in lecture
but we will not be going over the
details of how to do this in lecture
we're not going to teach you how to code
you already know how to code if you're
here in this class
so we're and like i said we're not going
to tell you what language to use
we're only going to tell you what api to
implement
and then you get to make a lot of the
choices after that
so somebody asked can we work solo um so
that's something that has been allowed
in the past
uh however i don't recommend it and so
we're mandating actually that the
project has to be done in groups of two
to three
um the reason for that is well
honestly fault tolerance right so what
if something happens
to one of the people in your group right
what if they have some sort of emergency
and they have to deal with
family issues for a while in the past
uh if you were working by yourself and
you have to deal with something like
that then you would really be in trouble
so we're trying to set up the course in
such a way that there's some kind of
fault tolerance so if some member of
your group
ends up unable to contribute for a
little while
then the group can still continue on and
then that person can pick back up later
another question that was just asked is
what are the most used languages and
frameworks
um so i have some thoughts on this but
because we're so close to the end of
uh end of this lecture uh i'm gonna save
it for maybe next time or
instead i'll just answer this question
offline on zulip
and i think also the course staff is
more qualified to speak on this than i
am because some of
all of the all the tutors have taken the
course before so
uh they know what was done um
you know let me just say so two really
popular choices
uh for language are python and go
so python obviously is what we teach our
intro courses here
here at ucsc uh so basically everybody
knows python
there are frameworks that are available
for both of these languages
go is a really nice choice you might not
have learned it in the regular
curriculum here but
but you can learn it i don't want any of
this to sound like i'm endorsing
either of those two languages at the
expense of other choices
people have done this project
successfully in java
they've done it successfully in node or
in other words javascript people have
done it successfully in c
although i don't necessarily recommend
it
and there are other options as well so
you could do it in haskell
so you really have a lot of choices and
we are not going to tell you what to do
uh somebody else just asked should we
find teammates now or after assignment
one well
um you could start thinking about where
to find teammates now
um we will not ask you to finalize your
team
uh until the end of week two so you
don't have to find your
your team uh until the end of week two
um so you don't have to you know run out
and find a team immediately
but i wouldn't wait until the very last
minute either because
you don't want to be stuck without a
team
all right any other questions on that
so as i mentioned people have done the
project before in c but
i i honestly don't recommend it i think
you're making your life too hard if you
try to do it in c
and you might ask you know well this is
a systems course why aren't we writing c
well it's it is a systems course
and we're doing a systems project but
the kinds of concerns that we're dealing
with in this course are different
from what you're dealing with in 130.
so that's why we don't mandate that you
use c
all right it's 4 55 so we should call it
quits for today
thank you for joining for this first
lecture
the video should be available basically
immediately and i'm going to post links
to twitch
um so you'll be able to watch that video
it's going to get archived on youtube
later
and thank you i really appreciate
everybody's participation in the chat
and i'm really happy i'm excited
i'll see you next time on thursday
and take care